mel i would love you please to plunge  that knife into simon cowell's chest  okay  mel b's got the knife and i'm going to  be murdered on live tv  and she's gonna love it the ratings will  probably go through the roof end of my  career but you know what i'll take it  what's it like picking on the boss  he's not my boss i'm the boss of me just  your average night of chaos on america's  got talent you are a  [Music]  mel b and simon cowell left the judges  table to participate in mentalist colin  clouds act on tuesday night clearly mel  had no problem getting into character i  gotta ask you though after last week how  nervous and how tense were you up there  knowing that she had that knife in her  hand what do you think you know i'm  looking at these knives thinking no they  are they look to me like real knives  and she actually wants to kill me i  could see it in her eyes  [Music]